women are generally lonely now because
you know without the hook up culture
because yes people are just like having
sex for for the sake of having sex like
do you think like women are lonely
nowadays a little bit because they're
scared a lot of the time a lot of girls
especially even like some of my friends
they'll have sex with a guy and they'll
be attached to that guy quite quickly
because an emotional thing and then the
guy is really not interested he's out
there to just hanging bad things so then
she's obviously going to be a bit upset
and then she gets upset and scared and
fearful of even getting those situations
i don't think i don't think that well i
don't think any girl that goes to
castillo looking for love is thinking
straight like you got a chicken
but he gets girls why did he got to
exactly because like this is what i'm
saying he there's there's girls
there's different types there's
different types of girls there's girls
and there's women there's boys and
there's men don't do that and then it's
true that's like the no true scotsman
listen you talk about rappers but
rappers in in how you was like saying oh
a real man would do this listen you told
me the crazy thing is they'll be like
cheated oh no oh my god why would you
expect even the girl in the 12 girl
rotation she seemed like a nice lady in
the video
and that's what i'm saying like when you
even talked about me being with a rapper
i'm sorry um you were saying this is why
sorry you were saying that you think
they're lonely why do you think women
are lonely i think mainly a lot of fear
and also i feel like women feel like
they need to give everything to men so
they might act in a certain way and they
might put on a front they might just try
and be that girl that a lot of pressure
yeah and then when it comes down to the
man isn't very interested or they
realize am i putting on a facade and i'm
not really being myself they start
thinking oh am i going to be ending up
like 40 and alone or being a fake
version of myself or something you've
also yeah you see the truth is
i think
good girls
they don't get lonely but modern females
they are lonely because they have this
delusional ideology and yes they may
sleep around with the bad boys stuff
like that but they they will soon
realize the bad boy don't even like you
he only likes what's between your legs
and you guys may try to bag him get in a
relationship but he don't want that
commitment so literally when you guys
come across the nice guys you guys don't
want them so it's like you guys don't
want it no
trust me
i do modeling and stuff and i meet a lot
of um also rappers and things like that
i've never ever dated one even if they
try and because i just know how they're
like and i'm not saying i know every
single how men things but like i know in
the industry i would even football is
like i would are you are you single
no okay so oh okay you you're you're
you're attached okay so you actually
back it up your boyfriend's nice yes he
is nice but there's certain things that
i don't like about him but i'm like what
did he do what did you say that on the
phone
how long have you been in this
relationship uh nearly a year because
the way you described that the way it
the relationship for three years the way
you're describing them like it's like
you don't really respect yourself
so why would you say what you're saying
can i ask a question
how many girlfriends have you had in
collingwood are you using the ship are
you single uh complicated yeah no okay
explain yourself that sounds like sign
language but go on yeah come on what is
that it's like a jigsaw puzzle that's
what i can say
that don't make sense so have you had a
relationship before a long-term
relationship no okay so
do you know what a woman wants yes why
are you single then am i single yes am i
single
well it's complicated i don't know
that's what i'm asking you don't need to
know oh okay but you want to be able to
know ours and judge ours but we can't
actually look at things on your side and
actually put it on a perspective to say
actually let's look at men for a second
because we can crucify women but let's
see also because he goes two ways he
takes two to tango that's real i can oh
i can be accountable for my mistakes but
it's not all me now listen this woman
are not accountable basically
men and men and women are measured by
different standards men are measured by
if they can get laid not a relationship
it's not like a badge of honor to get a
girlfriend anyone can get a girlfriend
and most you know some but but
for women we're measured by if we can
attain a relationship men are measured
by if they can get laid yeah because men
some men can actually enter into a
relationship and the girl don't actually
like him but he likes him for the
resources that he can provide for her is
that why you're suffering
i didn't say that okay so why don't you
have a girlfriend like a proper woman i
didn't say that why haven't you owned
the girl that you're having complicated
i said it's complicated why have you not
owned it yet howdy
i'm 22. okay i'm 21. look i'm 22. you're
21. i'm 22. so
if you're saying i should jump into a
relationship i need to focus on myself
and chase myself so i ain't got no time
you know for what i expect that if you
need to hustle you obviously need time
for yourself too that's fair enough but
for me obviously i said i'm in a
relationship and
i mean i know what he wants like i cook
for him all the time i clean his fat and
things like that and i'm not like i
would not do it all the time but i would
do it because i know he needs some help
too in this flat you know i don't
actually live there but i'm always with
her sorry can you hear me sorry yeah so
i know he's needs
i've been with him for nearly a year i'm
just doing what i think that would be
great for our relationship and he is
also trying his best is he marriage
material
yes i think so what you have yes there
was a hesitation there and also from
what you said before because you never
know like you never know what's out
there like i'm trying to make my mind
just open to anything i'm not saying
he's not the one i'm also not saying he
is the future but do you want to give
you want to like in general do you want
to have like a long-term partner a
long-term company i mean everyone i
think everyone would want yeah of course
if if it wasn't for the how my situation
was i would have had three three
children by now i want to be married you
don't have any children no and i'm very
grateful because this is the reason why
also a lot of women choose the lonely
past because
what i know this because my mom has had
experiences i'm a i'm a
i'm a child of a complicated home i love
my dad he was amazing but as a man to my
to my mom there was complications and i
understand that if you fall in love with
the wrong man and you put yourself in
this sort of situations things can
really go wrong for you and you as the
caretakers the mother
all of that trauma that your child is
going to take is going to be you that's
going to witness it's going to be you
that's going to have to take care of it
it's going to be you that's going to
suffer through your child because you're
the mother so that's also one of the
reasons why women are really afraid we
can't just blame women and say that
women are trash
but they shouldn't be afraid because
women leave they leave seventy to eighty
percent of the time if they're college
educated they leave ninety percent of
the time women are the ones that are
leaving okay and
and i'll explain now we can say women
leave fine out of those ninety people in
the uk
64 okay even the 64 now we can look at
the numbers and say oh that's alarming
okay but out of the 64 the women that
college educated why did they leave what
was the situation because this is really
this is a really common tactic it's like
whenever we hold women accountable for
something where there's always an excuse
self-defense yeah it's not an excuse
it's not it's it is okay i'll explain to
you it's like you're breaking up a home
that's that's breaking the fabric of
society that's the worst thing you can
do to your kid is put them in a
single-parent household and we're saying
well but why did she do it doesn't
matter what's worse single parent
household or household stock second
abusive where you grow up seeing for
example parents fantastic so why are you
now saying
that the majority of the reasons why
women are leaving is because they're
from toxic and abusive households i'm
just trying to bring to the table the
fact that numbers as many of you know i
was just banned on tick tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible